hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today's been a little bit weird if
you've hopped into for honor today
you've noticed that tester metal is
obviously gone
but there's a new event taking place for
some reason
out of the blue the everything is just
showing up and everything is just like
looking weird nothing really makes a
whole lot of sense
so we're gonna kind of talk about this
explain what the hell is going on and
just kind of maybe get some info out of
this thing so as always like if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new
let's get started with today's video so
yeah
there is some new event happening within
the game apparently it says 15 days left
and if you count down that timer that
roughly goes to august 6th which is also
the same day that the hero releases so
and if it wasn't obvious enough this is
definitely centered around the new hero
as for what we know we get a decent
chunk of info from the new game mode
tyrant's test
and so far for the names that i've
gotten it is the samara ghost
and astara i believe that is the male
and female name respectively
i've been seeing a couple people say
that they've gotten the warmonger name
which means that that might actually
just be the class name that we see
in game kind of like you get hitokiri
but her female name is sakura kind of
like that
i'm assuming that warmonger is going to
be the name of this character class
versus menu is also an interesting
change as she's killed all the bosses
from the tester metal event the new
character like i said is a slightly
different apollyon has very similar
moves that apollyon does but also has
very similar moves that apollyon doesn't
do
also has a bunch of new feats that i
tried to get out of this character to
use
they mostly seem to be dealing with a
lot of poison-esque things like a circle
where
when she hits you after she pops this
feet then
the next hit that hits you is going to
pop a circle on the ground and
it's fine for you at the moment but if
any player walks into that circle with
you they will take 12 damage a second
her alt is very similar where that
everyone gets a circle this time and the
same rules apply
if any person walks into another
person's circle that is about 12 or so
damage a second now this could have been
altered due to tester metal
the rules with that where the higher you
go up in the
winnings of that game the stronger they
get so that could have buffed the feat
but maybe it is the correct damage she's
got a couple unblockables a couple
faints that she can do with them to go
right into guard break
possibly a soft faint there with some of
the move she has a dash forward heavy
which is kind of a
like a stab and i believe that it's
undodgeable there's a lot of different
things going on with this character and
it seems very interesting and i was
actually getting my ass booked by this
character she's definitely a
force and you can even check on the
armor that
you notice with this character and it's
also just apollyon's armor with slight
modifications to it originally when i
saw this i thought that this was a
different apollyon
but then i realized that the new
character is probably similar to this as
we've been getting a lot of reports of
that
so it just seems like this is the new
character it looks like a polygon with
slightly different modifications
what does that mean i don't know maybe
this is due to the fact that you know
tester metal
during the tester metal event the whole
story with that is that people were
dressing up as the
you know the main bosses of the game
they weren't those weren't the actual
bosses this was just more of like an
honorary thing
where the players then fight the people
impersonating the bosses
this could be someone possibly
impersonating apollyon
but with a slightly different you know
kind of ideas that they have maybe they
don't want to have everybody fight or
you know different ideals ideologies or
whatever it happens to be
it seems like someone noticed what
apollyon did
really enjoyed what she did and wants to
do that exact same thing but maybe a
different way
one thing i noticed as well was a lot of
cheering and booing but how can you do
that with no
crowd i also noticed that when i would
kill the bosses i would get
booed as opposed to tester metal where
you'd get cheered for it as i checked
outside of the map
there's actually an entire crowd of her
army at the very gates of this map
waiting to charge in that is the people
cheering and booing
there's nobody else around the map that
i could find just this like
big large group of people outside the
map
of course we have all this info and
that's super great but none of it is
exactly concrete as i can go here and
explain to you what all the feats do
in my own experience from the game but i
also could be missing something slightly
happening with these feats that
i can't see as i'm the enemy being
affected by them
which means we have to wait for the
devstream to fully get all the answers
that we need on this character and what
the hell is even going on
so obviously we have three upcoming
devstreams we have the one tomorrow we
have the one a week from now and then we
have the one two weeks from now which is
also the release date of the character
are they gonna wait two weeks and then
do the release of the character and the
devstream at the same time
who knows are they gonna do it to us
tomorrow as we just got this event or
they're gonna let us wait a week
and then do it give us a little bit of
time to kind of figure out what the hell
we think is happening and then they'll
tell us what is actually happening
i don't know but either way in these
next couple weeks definitely stay locked
on the channel we're gonna have some
interesting videos coming out with this
stuff
very confused very intrigued but i'm
very confused yeah as always guys like
the view if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new
with that take care i'll see you in the
next live stream video for all this
madness
and peace out
[Music]
you